well I'm joined now by the military
analyst and retired Air Vice Marshal
Sean Bell and what do you think this
means for the course of of the conflict
in Ukraine yeah there's two main areas
to focus on first one is the Don bass as
ever there's been attacks and
counter-attacks some very determined
attacks by Russia very determined
defense by the ukrainians but as ever
with the offense you lose a lot of
people and Russia seems to be a man's
Camp huge casualties hey because they're
on the offense and B because they're
using an experienced soldiers but the
main focus has been down in hessen down
to the South here taken by Russia in
March of this year if you remember nice
and early it's the only major city that
was to fall the real worry was this was
a city and we are stepping stone to
Odessa it's also important though
because it provides some of the water
comes from the Juniper River down to
Crimea Russian occupied since 2014 and
also electricity from zapparicha power
plant so strategically housing was very
very very important Ukrainian strategy
has been to try to squeeze the Russian
forces out rather than fight their way
and blowing the bridges on the nepro
river one thing we heard yesterday
Russian defense Minister sir guy shogu
who ordered his troops for the Russian
withdrawal it was shown on television
very theatrical which always makes me a
little bit nervous they talked a lot
about the safe withdrawal of the Russian
forces clearly playing a domestic
audience but not a word from Putin all
of this I think we have to be very
careful to commentate on things we know
and what we don't know what we do know
is that there are verified reports of
Russian forces leaving the north of
danipro the north of Harrison
um but it's actually very very slow
progress to learn a lot to watch and why
now why do you think Russia appears to
be taking this action now well losing
hasn't would be a major setback for
Russia but it's very clear the Russian
priority is the donbass and at the
moment they've got potentially 20 000
soldiers trapped in a world trade
soldiers trapped in Harrison and if they
don't get them out soon they get taken
off the battlefield Russia clearly wants
to withdraw them out from there and then
redeploy them to their main effort up in
the donbass from from the Ukrainian
perspective they made an effort has been
hearsened for ever since August where
they've been squeezing Russian forces
there and the worry is that is this some
form of trap of this announcement the
reality is although the Russians are
undoubtedly be mining a lot of areas of
person and making it very difficult to
stop the ukr their withdrawal becoming a
route this was expected we've been
talking on this on Sky News for quite
some time that it was expected that
withdrawal why the theater though for me
is why all this television stuff because
from you never announced as a military
strategy what you're going to do on
television I think the main point there
is that if you remember when the
Russians withdrew from kharkiv back in
September up in the north they didn't
say a word and that was humiliating for
Russia it does appear this time they're
trying to get onto the front foot
particularly for the domestic audience
the Russians have lost tens of thousands
of soldiers they've had to mobilize
that's not played well back at home so
if you listen carefully it's the
rhetoric this was all about a safe
withdrawal looking after our soldiers
which undoubtedly is part of Saving
Lives but tellingly if you remember the
personal blast was now going to be
Russian forever stated by Putin Putin's
been completely quiet about all this
President zlinski on his part rains a
bit cautious maybe even skeptical about
you know he says the enemy does not give
us gifts so he's very skeptical about
going in but actually it probably suits
both parties Russia and Ukraine for them
to withdraw
um zielinski wants hessen back but he
wouldn't have wanted to have a major
battle to take it back and from a
Russian perspective they desperately
need the troops up to the north at Main
effort so it probably works their bet
advantage next steps though I think it's
no doubt this has been a really positive
development for Ukraine we've got
verified footage now from nirifka up in
the north there of the Russian
withdrawal from there and some lovely
footage of the Ukrainian forces
celebrating having taken at that City
let's be clear though the Russians will
not just walk out they will have a
fighting withdrawal there's a lot more
fighting to come it's also worryingly in
the news that obviously Russia is
approaching Iran to get more drones and
also potentially ballistic missiles so
this war is not over yet but this has
been a really positive development for
your Ukraine okay Sean thanks very much